the jurgen experience and i think one of
the problems from the 60s was this idea
of
you know one dose miracle cure that's
all you need
yeah and i think what we've come to
understand is that it's not that way
occasionally it can be but mostly it's
not and you need this support
afterwards and you need to integrate it
and what we've also learned from
neuroscience is that you're actually
neuroplasticity that these psychedelics
help you rewire your brain in new ways
but you have to reinforce that it's just
not
automatic it's not about the drug it's
about the therapy that the drug helps
make more effective
and people have placed undue confidence
you could say in the drug itself
you need a new pathway once you've
gotten off of your old pathway
the psychedelics jolt you into this new
realm
but if you don't have a new pathway then
you
you panic and people fall back into
their comfort zone
and if your comfort zone is alcohol
abuse
and doing the same things you've done
before and ruining your life and taking
pills and you're going to go right back
to that
yeah there's one example of one person
where it was like a one dose miracle
cure
it's really rare but i'll just explain a
bit he was a veteran
and had ptsd i talked about tony macy
during my
ted talk but he had this sense that he
had been disabled with ptsd for years
because of friends of his that had been
killed all the violence that he saw when
he was in iraq
and under the influence of mdma he had
this
realization that there was something
good about the ptsd he was getting a
benefit from it
which was it was the way that he showed
loyalty to his friends who had died that
he was connected to their memory and
that he was
suffering it was a way to be bonded
still with them
but then he was able to kind of see
himself from the eyes of his
friends who had died and to realize that
they wouldn't want him to squander his
life they didn't have life anymore
they would want him to live as fully as
possible and he realized there's another
way to honor his friends which is to
to live and he thought what am i going
to do with the rest of my life
and in that moment he cured himself of
ptsd
then he said i'm taking opiates for pain
but i don't really think i'm taking it
for pain i'm thinking
more about it as an escape i don't need
the opiates anymore
and then he said i don't need this mdma
anymore either i'm done i want to drop
out of the study this was his first
of what was going to be three mdma
sessions wow
and he dropped out and we said sure it's
all voluntary
but if you we'll just do the outcome
measures that would help us and he
agreed to do that
and at the two-month follow-up no ptsd
and then around 11 months when we have
the 12-month follow-up he started
thinking well maybe i'd like another
mdma experience
i said well we can't quite do that if
you're out of the protocol you've
dropped out but at least
it's only for ptsd this study let's see
what your scores are at
the 12 months and no ptsd and that was
about nine ten years ago
i've been in touch with him recently
he's doing great but it was this
realization that he was able to make
under the influence of one experience of
mdma
that enabled him to reinterpret
the way he could be loyal to his friends
who had died
that's amazing and it makes sense it
completely makes sense that that would
be one of the reasons why
a soldier would have ptsd you talk to
soldiers that experience combat duty one
of the things they say is
there's this insane profound connection
with
their fellow soldiers yes and when one
of them
is killed and they survive they have
this
survivor syndrome this survivor's guilt
yeah
and it it haunts them you know and if
they could honor the fallen soldiers by
living their best life and not being
in constant trauma it'd be better for
everybody
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience